[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24
más Romero sala nuevamente en el estudio
mar Hoy es el Día Internacional de la
lucha contra el cáncer de mama como ya
lo venimos hablando Cómo afecta de esta
enfermedad a las personas y a las
mujeres en todo el mundo pues Buenos
días Raúl es el tipo de cáncer más común
entre las mujeres más de 2,2 millones de
casos y diagnosticaron solo en 2020 y
una de cada 12 mujeres lo va a sufrir a
lo largo de su vida vamos a las cifras
del continente americano y casi medio
millón de nuevos casos anuales y más de
106.000 muertes en América Latina y en
el Caribe esto se transforma en 210.000
diagnósticos 68.000 muertes unas cifras
que son muy interesantes porque si te
das cuenta los diagnósticos son
significativamente menos que la mitad
pero las muertes son más que la mitad
que nos dice eso que en América Latina y
el Caribe en comparación con el resto
del continente americano mueren más
mujeres la proporción de mortalidad es
más alta qué masa Tenemos también es
importante decir que para el 2040 se
cree que se proyecta que va a aumentar
casi en un 40% el caso de nuevos
diagnósticos hasta
68.684.000 anuales y 162.000 muertes un
reto que pues se avecina en nuestra
región madre Cuál es la supervivencia de
un canso de un caso de cáncer de mama
pues la verdad es que depende bastante
depende de muchos factores en qué
momento se detecta no Por ejemplo si se
detecta temprano cuando todavía está
localizado es decir que no se ha
expandido Es verdaderamente alta en la
tasa de mortalidad el pronóstico es muy
bueno mientras que cuando el cáncer ya
ha hecho metástasis se ha expandido al
resto del cuerpo el pronóstico puede ser
más complejo o por ejemplo pues el tipo
de cáncer triple negativo para el cual
hay terapias que existen hoy en día que
funcionan para otros cáncer que para
cáncer de mama me refiero que para este
en particular no funciona Pero también
depende de muchos factores sociales en
los países catalogados como los pobres
los países con menos recursos solo el
40% de las mujeres sobreviven a cinco
años vista a partir del diagnóstico a
este tipo de cáncer una tasa pues la que
choca mucho por ejemplo cuando la
comparamos con la de Estados Unidos pero
es que incluso en países como Estados
Unidos donde hay acceso a tratamientos
Se supone donde se supone que hay amplia
concienciación y mecanismos para
detectar el cáncer las mujeres hispanas
y las mujeres afrodescendientes por
ejemplo tienen tasas incluso más bajas
de supervivencia mar y también en las
últimas décadas ha habido una larga
historia de campañas para concientizar
sobre el cáncer de mama hablemos un poco
sobre esto Sí de hecho cumple 30 años el
lazo rosa este mismo año no un lazo que
se ha convertido en un símbolo de la
lucha contra el cáncer de mama la creó
en Estados Unidos una empresaria Evelyn
loader de estherloder y de también creó
una fundación para investigaciones del
cáncer de seno no es indudable que desde
entonces en estos 30 años ha aumentado
muchísimo la conciencia que existe
alrededor de esta enfermedad los
tratamientos también ha mejorado
muchísimo el pronóstico para las mujeres
y las personas que son diagnosticadas de
este cáncer pero es muy interesante
Porque desde el principio vemos que la
idea que tenía Pues a la compañía de
este era asociar este lazo a la venta de
productos para recaudar fondos para la
investigación algo que es un propósito
bien loable pero que en algunos casos ha
llegado a salirse de las manos qué
ejemplos tenemos sobre estomar digamos
que en general hay críticas por hacer
este marketing alrededor de la salud y
la vida de las personas porque deja por
fuera pues historias más oscuras
alrededor del cáncer de lo que es
transitar la enfermedad Deja fuera
preguntas sobre cómo limamos estas
desigualdades de las que estábamos
hablando pero digamos que también hay un
problema hasta ejemplos bien sonados
hemos recopilado tres pero hemos
encontrado muchos muy rápidamente no por
ejemplo hay una publicidad de 2017 una
botella de tequila tequila Alacrán que
vende su botella con un lazo rosa va a
donar la mitad de pues del precio de la
botella unos 50 dólares a la
investigación pero es que el alcohol
está demostrado que es uno de los
factores que aumenta el riesgo de sufrir
cáncer de mama Entonces es algo
absolutamente contradictorios siguiendo
en esta línea un ejemplo más reciente de
este mismo año de este mismo mes en
octubre una destilería estadounidense
que en la misma tónica no va a donar
tres dólares por una botella rosada de
Ginebra no que van a que van a vender
tres dólares respecto a lo que no
sabemos Cuál es el precio pero
seguramente va a ser bien alto nos hace
dudar un poco de que con qué motivo
están haciendo realmente este tipo de
campañas si solo al final subirse al
carro por subirse al carro no de un mes
en el que todo se tiñe de Rosa y por
último no son solo las empresas las que
venden alcohol sino también hay ejemplos
de medios de comunicación que para este
mes preparan bebidas rosas para combatir
o para concienciar sobre el cáncer de
mama algo que como decíamos es
absolutamente contradi No aquí pues
hablaban de una de una receta de un
cóctel en particular que también iba a
donar cinco dólares a una organización
civil para luchar o para mejorar pues la
investigación el cáncer de mama no algo
que de verdad es un contrasentido ya que
muestra que a veces realmente se nos
olvida poner a las pacientes y a los
pacientes en el centro no van a analizar
esta enfermedad mar Muchísimas gracias